okay so I guess we're all happy to us
start the afternoon session with stokey
on Globus talk on algorithms well so
again I'm if Nokia nikolova I'm an
assistant professor at the University of
Texas at Austin i'll talk about
algorithms for risk mitigation in
networks and here is my motivation the
main feces of this talk will be that
uncertainty and risk can dramatically
change the design of algorithms and also
tools for analysis of algorithmic game
theory and mechanism design for example
in the context of transportation
networks we may need fundamentally
different algorithms for computing what
is the optimal route when the decision
maker or driver is risk-averse in
corresponding algorithmic game theory
models congestion games which model
multiple drivers let's say many
fundamentally different tools for
analysis in terms of what is the
resulting equilibrium or traffic
assignment in the network and
consequently the resulting congestion
and consequently then we may need to
revisit what is an elegant theory of
optimal tools which is one way for
alleviating congestion and all of these
models even if they are theoretical
abstractions and not precisely reality
are still essential to understand to
give us some hope to tackle what is now
one of the grand challenges of our
present-day society that of traffic
congestion which was measured to be 126
billion dollars in just highway
congestion costs in 2013 and is
projected to increase by another fifty
percent by the year 2030 and so this is
the structure of my talk I'll have 3 May
topics first i'll tell you what i mean
by risk and what are different
approaches to modeling defining risk
aversion and then i'll tell you about
the design of algorithms forest covers
decision makers and then algorithmic
game theory models in analysis when we
have multiple risk averse
decision-makers interacting with each
other and conclude with some open
directions so what is risk although
everybody somehow knows what risk is
there is no one clear mathematical
agreed-upon definition of risk instead
there are multiple approaches that were
developed independently the main one
from economics which models risk-averse
decision makers is known as expected
utility theory and this is still
prevalent theory very widely used
although it has its criticisms and now
he has various alternatives in finance
orthogonal e we have the mark of its
mean variance framework and related
frameworks and recently and now we have
seen a development of a modern risk
theories so I'll very briefly mention a
little more detail on these three
approaches I will not talk about
systemic risk so I will be mostly
talking about risk from the point of
view of an individual decision makers
such as an individual driver trying to
get to the airport on time systemic risk
is something also really important than
interesting to me and also very
important to I believe variety of
problems we look at in engineering
computer science a natural sciences but
still I don't understand it very well
it's something I hope to understand a
little better in the future and for now
I just give a pointer to a very long
100-page survey by people in finance
also on something else I will not talk
about is the notion of dynamic or
multi-period risk which is again very
important to dynamic
in real-time decision making problems
but again I hope that we can gain a
better understanding of that in in the
future so expected utility theory is
postulates that risk preferences can be
represented by a utility function which
is essentially a function from random
variable story all numbers and it says
that an individual prefers random
variable X to random variable Y or
lottery x2 lottery wise is trimmed in
economics if and only if they're
expected give atif or this random
variable is greater than greater than or
equal to the expected utility of debt
random variable and so this theory
essentially compresses random variables
to numbers because we really only know
how to compare numbers and so from their
own decision-making comes down to
working with with those single numbers
and now there's a prescriptive theory in
not necessarily descriptive in the sense
that it is built on two axioms
independence in continuity which has
been shown to not necessarily hold in
practice nevertheless it's still a very
useful very prevalent theory of decision
making and I just mentioned here now
that there are also many other
alternatives such as ambiguity theory
prospect theory and so on again i point
to the survey for the alternative
theories also cannoli Markowitz in 1952
was is viewed as the first one to
quantify risk in the context of
portfolio optimization in finance and he
postulated that risk should be
represented by the variance of a
portfolio and such decision making a
decision under uncertainty can be seen
as the trade-off between risk and
rewards in those various different
models so I've just written down the
equivalents in optimization theory
constrained optimization which would be
for example maximizing our return
subject to a budget on the variance
maximum the variance or the risk that we
can handle in unconstrained optimization
we can view this framework is optimizing
a linear combination of risk in return
for example maximize return minus some
multiple times the variance we can also
view the problem as a multi-criteria
optimization problem where we don't
really know our trade off between our
desired trade-off between risk and
reward but we are interested in all the
non dominated risk/reward pairs this is
defined as the Pareto frontier or
efficient mean variance frontier in
finance something that also belongs to
this mean variance framework is the
concept of value at risk which is
essentially the alpha quantile of the
distribution of a random variable and
it's widely used in finance now for
measuring the risk of various financial
positions something else in optimization
thats related to this framework is dead
of chance constraints so that's an
optimization problem in which we have
this random variable XL and one of the
constraints is a soft constraint in the
sense that we want the probability that
our random variable exceeds some given
budget c is at least some given desired
probability alpha so some of the
criticisms of this overall mark of its
mean variance frame worker that it may
lead to non monotone outcomes or
decisions for example since i'll be
talking about transportation as an
example let me say if we're choosing
between two routes one that OS x 1 hour
to reach the airport another one that
always takes one hour or 50 minutes
clearly the first one dominates the
second one but this framework may
penalize the second one because it has a
positive variance and so it may prefer
the first one that always takes one hour
I mentioned it because it's a known
drawback but it may or may not be a
drawback in the context of
transportation or other non-financial
situations where certainly certainly has
its value for also some of those
outcomes of the mean variance framework
are that it may lead to non convexity so
some of those for example value at risk
or chance constraints are very well
known non convex problems whereas one
may argue that a reasonable risk averse
decision-maker should prefer convex
position so the convex combination of
two portfolios should be no worse than
the individual portfolios so because of
the various drawbacks with this theory a
new theory was developed starting in
nineteen ninety nine so quite fairly
recently with the work of arson airtel
who said that we should assume an
axiomatic approach to defining risk so
we should state down certain axioms that
make sense that risk averse decision
makers should satisfy should have in
mind for example monotonicity if a given
portfolio always gives us non-negative
reward then the risk should be less than
or equal to 0 similarly convexity which
I mentioned already and in a few others
some of the other axioms have been put
into question whether we really need
some or not so without axiom three for
example risk measures that satisfy the
remaining three axioms are called convex
risk measures so now there is a lot of
research taken up by convex analysis
researchers and finance people are on
what are the properties of such convex
or coherent risk measures what our risk
measures that satisfy these axioms and
so on and I'll just mention one example
of such
coherent risk measure is the conditional
value at risk so I mentioned the value
at risk earlier which is the percentile
of a random variable and the conditional
value at risk is essentially the
expectation of the tail of this random
variable so if we are thinking of an
objective function which is getting to
the airport on time so we have a fixed
budget and we really want to make the
trip within one hour otherwise we'll
miss our plane so we have a clear-cut of
penalty if we come after that one hour
the plane has left so whether we are
late by one minute or half an hour we
have an equal penalty well conditional
value-at-risk tells us that we should
care about how much we are late so
instead of having just the same penalty
for all the undesired events in the in
the tail we should take the expectation
of the tail and this is one such a
coherent risk measure in one remark is
that when X is normally distributed
random variable both the value at risk
which is still very prevalent in finance
in the conditional value at risk which
so far has mostly been used in research
and hasn't been adopted in practice are
equal to the mean minus K times standard
deviation for for appropriate constants
K and I mentioned it because this is one
objective that I'll be using in some of
the coming models so what are the
challenges of algorithms for risk-averse
decision makers and now come back again
to routing in shortest paths that's just
one fundamental problem that everyone is
familiar with but more generally if we
consider a combinatorial problem where
we are looking to get some feasible
solution for example a path that equals
the hoof cost equals the sum of costs of
individual elements for example the
edges that make up the path so if now is
that we don't have given numbers for the
costs of different elements but they
said we have random variables for
example in
transportation networks we really don't
know how much time it takes us to go
from here to San Francisco it's a random
variable so think of the travel time is
those costs now if we have if we assume
independent random independent element
costs which we want assumption that I'll
use throughout the talk not necessarily
realistic but a starting point risk
neutral solution doesn't care about the
risk and just wants to measure the
expectation of the solution and by
linearity of expectation we can very
easily reduce the stochastic problem to
the corresponding deterministic problem
so assure this path problem remains a
shortest path problem with respect to
the mean travel time of the edges so
nothing new there we can just use the
well known algorithms if now we make one
step away from risk neutrality and want
a risk-averse objective for example
represented by an exponential utility
function so my objective is to minimize
the expectation of the e to the power my
my travel time in this case so we can
view that as exponential utility or we
can view it as what's known as entropic
risk measure which takes the log of this
so just mathematically notice that this
leads again to an additive separable
problem where the risk or utility
associated with the entire path is just
the sum of risk or utilities costs I
should say of the individual edges or
elements and so again we have reduced
the problem to a standard deterministic
problem so again we can apply the
algorithm that we know so beyond that it
was observed it has been observed time
and again in the literature is now
various folk theorem that if we deviate
from the linear and exponential utility
pretty much every other utility cannot
give us this nice additive form and so
we would optimizing the expected utility
in this case would lead to a nonlinear
or non convex problem which
algorithmically becomes very different
and we don't really know how to handle
I'll just mention again this is under
utility theory if we think of the mean
variance framework and again think of
those as independent random variables
the variance of the sum of two
independent random variables is the sum
of the two variances so again we would
have an additive problems so if our
criterion is min plus variance so
minimize the mean plus variance of my
path is a way of capturing risk we would
again come down to the familiar
deterministic shortest path problem but
again in most other instances we would
not so what do we do in other instances
beyond those two or three simple
objective functions so the challenge
here becomes that for example in
shortest paths since I mentioning how
things become different from the
deterministic setting the optimal
substructure a property that allows us
to use dynamic programming to solve the
shortest path problem will fail so what
do I mean by optimal substructure that's
the property that as a subset of our
optimal solution is optimal on the
corresponding smaller problem for
example if you think of the given
numbers here as travel times or or
distances the optimal path from A to C
is the right path and if i just take a
to be the optimal path from A to B
should still be the red path so a subset
of my optimal red path remains optimal
on the smaller sub graph from A to B
well this is the property that fails if
we want for example a min plus standard
deviation objective function so if we
are interested in finding the path that
minimizes its expectation plus the
standard deviation with the given
numbers here mean and standard deviation
say F travel times on each edge we can
quickly check that the optimal path from
a to see is I believe the red one and
from A to B is actually the blue one so
let's just make the calculation for for
for sanity check from A to B the top
edge the red one has been to a standard
deviation equal to eight where is the
bottom one here 7.9 and so it's optimal
to go on the bottom where is going from
A to C we would prefer to go along the
red route through out so we lose this
optimal substructure and therefore we
cannot use the traditional dynamic
programming methods and just all the
other types of algorithm sofa that have
been used for solving shortest paths and
again this challenge is linked to the
non convex in this case concave
objective that is the mental of standard
deviation objective so how can we solve
the problem in this case if this is our
goal if our goal is to minimize the mean
plus standard deviation of a path what
can we do so I turned to optimization at
a time when I was thinking about the
problem and I saw that again not much is
known in the area of global optimization
and we had to develop a solution from
first principles and the solution was
based on three insights the first
insight is that even though if we think
of the incidence vector of a path it's a
vector of having a coordinate for each
edge with one for the edge which is in
the path and zero otherwise this vector
is in dimension equal to the number of
edges and so if we think of the problem
in this case the objective function min
plus standard deviation is also a
function in a fairly big dimension
dimension of the number of edges but we
can actually think of the problem is
two-dimensional because all we care
about is the path mean and the path
standard deviation which is square root
of the path variance and so we can just
project our entire problem the feasible
set and the objective function on the
mean variance plane
in here the red dots correspond to
different feasible paths with x and y
coordinate equal to the mean and
variance of the path and let us now
understand our objective function the
path min plus some constant R times the
square root of the path variance his
level sets that are parabolas level sets
are the curves where the function the
objective function he has the same value
everywhere and they're parabolas that
have higher values is on higher
parabolas in this case we are interested
in the minimum min plus standard
deviation path so we would be interested
in sort of the the first time a parabola
from the bottom hits our feasible set
and so we can see geometrically visually
on this picture that the optimal
solution is this path right here so this
is our optimal solution this is the path
that he has the smallest min plus
standard deviation in so now to say that
silly the solution does not have the
yeah okay sure sure yeah it doesn't have
to be unique that's correct yes so we
may have one or multiple paths that are
their optimal we are interested in one
of them but even if it's not unique what
we what I want to remark next is inside
3 that the parabolas would necessarily
first hit the feasible set on an extreme
point of the feasible set and so the
solution must be one of those extreme
points so for example those paths in
science would never be one of the
optimal ones but we have at least narrow
down to the extreme points and this is
of course the well-known property of
concave functions that the minimum of a
concave function is attained at the
extreme points of the feasible set and
so that immediately suggests one
algorithm if we want to find the optimum
enumerate all the extreme points and
evaluate each of them met our objective
function pick the best one and this is
as far as I I know the state of art in
concave minimization we don't really
know for general concave minimization
what what else to do what better to do
and so we can enumerate all the past but
of course algorithmically immediately we
can ask what is the complexity of such
an algorithm it depends on the number of
extreme points and if there are many
that would lead to a very inefficient
algorithm or in the case of shortest
paths it turned out that they are not so
many so there is an exact algorithm that
goes through the extreme points and we
don't necessarily need all the extreme
points so I didn't mention here that we
only need extreme points on the lower
left of the feasible set and this is
important because those extreme points
here correspond to longest path
instances which we do not know how to
find algorithmically but those extreme
points here on the lower left we can
find because for example the lowest
point corresponds to the path with
smallest variance and so since variance
is as I mentioned earlier an additive
problem it's a we can find it with a
deterministic shortest path algorithm
will take two variances is the element
as the edge costs similarly the path on
the left most there is the path with
smallest mean and again we can find that
algorithmically and similarly we can
find all the points in between so what
is the complexity of this algorithm it
is determined by the number of extreme
points which in shortest paths turns out
to be n to the log n how do you find the
points in between by assuming some kind
of combination various yeah so so there
are multiple methods for finding the
point in between one of them is some
kind of binary search for example start
with finding this one in this one and
then draw the diagonal and use it is
your next objective for the trade off
and then keep that will find this point
and then
between this and this look for the ones
in between and keep going and so you
would require at most two times as many
iterations as there are extreme points
to find all of them and make sure that
you have found all of them there are
other algorithms as well it's it's an
interesting problem in parametric
shortest paths where if you start with
this one can you find the next one and
then the next one so find them in order
this that's another type of algorithm in
and there are various variants of of
those and so again in shortest paths the
number of such extreme points is n to
the log n that's a really interesting
result actually from the 1980s the upper
bound is easy to establish the lower
bound is a highly non-trivial graph
construction with very carefully
determined weights a and B / edge and so
to this day our best solution here is an
exact algorithm that has a super
polynomial complexity so it's likely not
an np-hard problem but at the same time
we don't know if this problem can be
solved in polynomial time we have a
conjecture whether on planar graph we
can establish that the number of such
extreme points is polynomial again we
haven't really made progress on that yet
so I just mentioned some interesting
problems along the way but this is
something that practitioners probably
don't care about at all they just care
what is the performance of these
algorithms in practice and in practice
this algorithm was adapted and
implemented in actually a real real time
traffic project at MIT called Kartel
where they measure textual traffic on
the Boston roads network in with this
algorithm they were able to find various
risk averse risk minimizing paths and
they observed that the running time was
very fast because in practice often it
just boiled down to enumerate in about
10 extreme points between representative
source and destination points in Boston
and so I ran also simulations on grid
graphs with uniformly random weights
just to understand what is the number of
extreme points that we may observe and
the results were always very encouraging
there was a very small number of extreme
points and this was confirmed by a
smooth analysis type result that we had
subsequently which established that if
we perturb the mean variance a little
bit then in expectation with respect to
this perturbation the number of extreme
points is very small so what's typically
that's all so I can just give the
anecdotal evidence of the MIT project
which came down to listing about 10
extreme points overall the entire will
just take take one example I meaning in
graphs typically all the number the
number of total number of past is
exponential right so you can easily see
that in examples in this MIT um so I
don't so that's a typical road network
and now you're asking what is the total
number of paths in a typical road
network and again think of the Manhattan
grid so you can write so I think in many
real-world problems you would have an
exponential number of almost all of them
must be unrealistic probably so and in
fact the algorithm that was implemented
was doing a little pruning in addition
to this enumeration so he didn't just
brute-forcing numerator all the extreme
point I did a little bit of pruning but
still in theory with pruning we cannot
we cannot prove that we can get
something less than a super polynomial
this problem also has a seems like it
should have a polynomial to approximate
scheme right absolutely so this is the
next thing so once we have a polynomial
smoothed analysis we can convert that
easily into an epsilon in this case we
got an epsilon additive approximation
with different methods later I was able
to establish a multiplicative 1 plus
epsilon approximation and so indeed it's
possible and in fact is possible to do
not only for shortest paths but for
general arbitrary combinatorial problems
for which you just you know an
underlying deterministic an algorithm
for the deterministic problem and you
use it as a black box to solve the
corresponding risk-averse or or non
convex problem this is just for the
objective function which is mean plus
standard deviation or so this why now
I'm becoming more vague and I mentioned
risk averse functions i was talking
about mean plus standard deviation but
we didn't really need anything about min
plus standard deviation other than the
fact that it's a concave function and so
it's optimum must be one of the extreme
points you also be the shortest spot it
is for the shortest part it was for the
shortest path in as much as we needed to
find the extreme points but now what
what I'm saying is that we can have a
generic problem combinatorial
optimization problem for which which is
let's say the minimization problems so
find me and a feasible object of minimum
cost so you give me an algorithm for
that problem it's essentially a linear
problem right a problem with linear
objective and I say that I can solve for
any function which is low rank in this
case Rank 2 I mean it's a two
dimensional function one that can be
thought of as two dimensions so as long
as it's concave and the optimum is an
extreme points beyond that I don't need
anything about the property of the
function the extreme points are
completely independent of the function
and I only use the funk
at the very end once they have
enumerated the points I just go back and
evaluate my objective function each of
them in order to pick the best one and
so in this sense the enumeration based
algorithms they're independent of the
objective functions and they in the work
for any objective function for which the
optimum must be one of the extreme
points and the class of such functions
is well then it includes concave
functions it includes quasi concave
functions which is a generalization and
you know various other functions if they
just add up things on edges it should be
sublinear let's concave I mean that's
any sub linear functional if you add up
things on edge assuming links on edges
or something you add a power of those
lengths over the entire path as long as
the power is less than 1 it will be
concave and you can do it yeah
okay so let me just mention and and
again I kept this vague in terms of what
risk averse function and I mentioned it
we can do it for concave functions so if
we want the interpretation of a
risk-averse decision-maker what
risk-averse functions can we handle so
mean to a standard deviation is one of
them another one that's very natural is
minimizing the probability that you're
late or minimizing the probability that
your solution exceeds a given budgets
and I'll mention one more after that and
so if we have such a risk-averse
objective which reduces to a concave
problem then we can essentially solve
this concave problem with a black box
reduction to the corresponding
deterministic or linear problem and we
would be using this linear problem as a
subroutine and invoke it polynomially
many times so this is the theorem in
fact we can solve the risk averse or or
concave problem not only if we have an
exact algorithm for the underlying
deterministic problem but even if we
have just an approximation algorithm so
if we have a delta approximation for the
deterministic problem we would have
almost the same approximation for the
corresponding risk averse or concave
problem and so again I mentioned the
three risk averse objectives that I have
I have thought of so far that following
this framework of concave minimization
are mean plus standard deviation
minimizing the probability that the cost
of my solution exceeds a given budgets
in routing minimize the probability that
we are late or minimize the budget such
that the probability of exceeding it is
at most a given desired confidence level
Tyrion you seem something well it is
true yeah you're right yeah I put the
stairs here and then I'm asked the note
in the stairs yeah so for normal
distributions those come down to in fact
they become equivalent to concave
problems thank you and for other
distributions we can again do some kind
of approximation tech Chernoff bounds
and again we would come down to similar
concave problems so let me go to a
challenge of moving to more general
risk-averse objectives or more general
utilities so depending on our risk
averse objective for utility the problem
may may incorporate longest path as a
problem and such be np-hard we still can
approximate just for shortest paths we
can approximate general non Juan Antonio
tivities and again get an arbitrarily
good approximation I'm also interested
in moving to a more dynamic or adaptive
decision making you know welcome to that
result at the end but now let me come
down to the problem of multiple risk
averse decision makers so far I said if
we have a single decision maker who is
risk averse what are the algorithms that
this decision maker can use to find the
solution they need now if again we think
of the context of transportation if I
give every risk averse driver the same
outcome and they go through that route
they can gesture out that will not be
very good so we need to adopt a game
theory model to take into account the
interaction between multiple drivers or
the effect they have on each other and
this is a the well-known example of
brace paradox which I don't have time to
go through but i'll just mention is the
paradox we are adding a road can
sometimes increase congestion can be two
more traffic and this is linked to this
concept of price of energy that has
become very predominant now in the study
of algorithmic game theory in many
problems the price of anarchy measures
the degradation of system
Foreman's do too selfish behavior or a
little more precisely it measures the
ratio of the costs that we experience in
the worst Nash equilibrium that is when
players play their individually optimal
strategies in rich and Nash equilibrium
versus the cost in the system if a
central decision maker a central
coordinator decided where everyone
should go and so this price of energy
i'll just mentioned was measured to be
was analyzed to be four thirds in
general graphs with linear latency
functions that indicate their functions
of the travel time as a function of
number of users or flow on the edge and
so i wanted i started to talk by saying
that the main thesis of the talk is that
risk and uncertainty can dramatically
change system performance and the
properties of resulting equilibria in
this case and so here what i want to
demonstrate is that in a particular
model of uncertainty various risk-averse
preferences made it two very different
types of price of anarchy so i will not
go into the different definitions here
but i just want to mention that under
various risk averse models we can have
anywhere from a small constant price of
energy to unbounded price of anarchy and
the gain price of anarchy measures the
degradation of system performance due to
selfish behavior and so we conclude here
that the the modeling of risk and
uncertainty can very critically affect
our prediction of system performance and
thus it should really be taken into
account when we're thinking of system
design as well and this work is just one
of now a growing number of works or
research on risk aversion in routing
games and to zoom in a little more into
one of these models our goal with that
no it's just another picture to bring
your mind back to transportation and the
challenges of congestion so we want to
understand the effect of risk itself on
congestion so how much we know that
selfish behavior leads to some
congestion in the sense of increased
overall system costs but now what is can
we decouple just the effective risk
averse attitudes from that of selfish
play on congestion so that is our goal
here and so in sequence of papers we
analyze various properties of
equilibrium and then we came up with
this new concept of price of risk
aversion which I felt bad since there
are so many prices prices of price of X
price of wine so on in the field of
algorithmic game theory we have price of
Anarchy price of stability prices that
coordination is also I felt guilty for
introducing yet another notion but we
couldn't come up with a better name so
this simply refers to the price that
society has to pay in increased
congestion or increased system costs due
to risk risk averse attitudes of the
individual players and so our model is
just a natural generalization of the
classic game theory model of routing
games or congestion games which is we
are given a directed graph with the
general model has multiple source
destination pairs but in this one we
just look at a single source destination
pair and we think of the players is
small particles of a flow so it's a non
atomic model so the players are
infinitesimally small relative to the
whole population a niche player wants to
get from the source to the destination
via a certain path so the strategy
strategy set is the set of available
paths from s to T so we can encapsulate
the strategy the resulting decisions of
players is a flow back
they're a flow vector in the space of
all paths so we would have one
coordinate for every path which tells us
how much flow is routed along that
pattern or how many drivers just to go
along that path and in classic
congestion games or routing games we
just have a latency function or H delay
function which is a function l e of XE
of the flow on the edge now we want to
introduce a certain team so we say we
can think of this is the expected delay
and we have noise additionally we assume
independent noise across the edges and
so the noise here is just some random
variable with mean 0 and some given
standard deviation which again may or
may not depend on the slow on the edge
and so now again for the sake of
studying somewhere we assume that the
players want to find minimum risk paths
defined by the mean standard deviation
objective we also look at the mean
variance objective because it's easier
computationally and for the sake of
comparison so again in mean standard
deviation everyone wants to minimize the
mean to the standard deviation on a path
and in the mean variance players instead
want to minimize the mean plus variance
on the path and remember that in the
mean variance objective things are
additive so computationally they are
easy we can find the mean the minimum
mean variance path easily so I should
tell you now what is the notion of an
equilibrium this is the natural
generalization of Nash equilibrium which
is known as wardrobe equilibrium in the
context of congestion games wardrop I
beliefs define the concept almost at the
same time when Ash was defining Nash
equilibrium and so the equilibrium
simply is a set of paths one for each
player such that nobody has the
incentive to deviate so no one can
switch to a path with smaller costs and
by costs here I think of the mean
standard deviation costs or or the
variants cost but of course the
equivalent definition holds for any
other risk averse definition and I'll
differentiate a little later on between
a risk-averse equilibrium and a risk
neutral equilibrium so this is the
equilibrium where the cost here is just
the expected delay of the path
so I'll just mention very briefly since
I'm running out of time that we
characterize first of all the existence
of equilibria in this model in the mean
standard deviation model that's the more
challenging model and immediately we see
in the classic model we have a small
convex program so the equilibrium can be
found computationally here sometimes
it's a convex program but it's
exponentially large so we cannot
necessarily solve it quickly and
sometimes there is no equilibrium
furthermore another challenge is that if
we happen to magically find the
equilibrium in terms of how much flow
should be routed along each edge and we
now want to decompose it to say how much
flow should go on each path this is a
non-trivial problem not every path slow
decomposition of a given edge flow
equilibrium vector is an equilibrium
nevertheless we can show non
constructively that an equilibrium or a
socially optimal traffic assignment
there exists equilibria and socially
optimal assignments which use only
polynomially many paths but still we we
don't know how to find them in terms of
price of anarchy we understand what
happens when the standard deviations are
constants on each edge they don't depend
on the flow it's the same as the
deterministic price of Anarchy the
corresponding results for the
deterministic games but we don't know
what happens for non non constant
standard deviations but now again I want
to come back to this question of
decoupling the effect of risk from the
effect of selfish behavior in terms of
contribution to overall congestion or
system costs and so we define this
concept of price of risk aversion which
measures the cost ratio of costs of risk
averse equilibrium to cost of risk
neutral equilibrium so if everyone is
risk-averse in the hell they choose
their out how much more would they
travel relative to if people didn't care
about variability in risk
and here is one two example just to
build a little intuition if we have a
choice of two routes from s to t 1 you
need a flow that we need to route across
and we just need to decide how much flow
X should go on top and the remaining 1
minus X to go on the bottom if we have
the corresponding mean variance
parameters over there so here k is just
some parameter they've chosen and
they're on top of postulated that the
mean is a function of the flow x it's
the flow x times someone plus RK where r
is my risk averse coefficient yeah thank
you that's very critical question and I
kind of swapped it on the drug here so
for the purpose of this slide and on
coming slides the cost of a flow will be
with respect to risk neutral users and
with we justified by saying it makes
sense from the point of view of a
central planner who cares about
long-term averages and so the cost of
flow is just the sum of expected travel
times so in the cost we don't factor
variance and that way we can also don't
compare apples and oranges but we
compare both flows with the same
it's not necessarily it's not
necessarily so sometimes the risk-averse
attitudes may help reduce congestion so
that's an interesting question we
haven't focused so much on that we
wanted to see if it hurts how much does
it hurt so in this case I just want you
to notice that if my objective function
and I again here I'm switching to a mean
variance objective function so users
want to minimize the mean plus R times
the variance so r is some risk averse
coefficient so on the bottom they will
face a cost of 1 plus R K on the top
they will face 1 plus R k times x which
is less than or equal to 1 so
risk-averse users will always face
weekly lower costs on the top Sao Paulo
risk-averse users will route on top so
when risk-averse users out on top this X
becomes one and they will experience the
cost of 1 plus RK the risk-neutral users
who don't care about the variance will
route on top and on bottom and in
equilibrium the top and bottom will have
equal expectation expected delay which
will be 1 so the cost of risk neutral
users will be 1 and so this ratio how
much more that we travel in the
risk-averse equilibrium will be 1 plus
RK over 1 so the price of risk aversion
this ratio will be 1 plus RK so again k
here was some arbitrary parameter that I
said for the variance r is given by my
input the degree of risk aversion so
people care to minimize the mean plus R
times the variance and so as you see
with K growing large this ratio may
become unbounded which is not a very
interesting and it somehow is very
pessimistic a prediction that risk
averse users may travel arbitrarily long
more than there is neutral users well in
practice it is natural to assume that
the variance is not too much larger than
the
in this is captured by the mean two
variants ratio so if we assume that the
variance to mean ratio is at most K some
given k then in this case the price of
risk aversion is one plus RK for this K
and this was for this very simple
network for a very general for for a
general graph what we were able to
establish is that the price of risk
aversion is at most 1 plus R K times an
additional beta parameter which depends
on the topology of the network and in
the worst case is an overt or the number
of vertices over 2 and I don't have time
to go over the details of the analysis
but i'll just mention that the analysis
is very different from the previous the
classic price of anarchy types of
analysis and most notably the result
depends on the network topology so the
price of anarchy result which I
mentioned price of anarchy is
four-thirds for all graphs with linear
latencies there is a constant for all
types of network topologies here if the
graph is series parallel ETA is one if
it's the bread gravity is too but in the
worst case it can be as large as the
number of vertices over two we have
fulfill your correct yeah 44 series
peril the price of anarchy is actually
lower and so that actually is because of
a different perspective of how to
analyze this system losses or the system
degradation we have a different type of
analysis which is against more in line
with a traditional price of Anarchy
which says that the price of risk
aversion is at most the price of Anarchy
inflated by our risk coefficient so let
me is here here we assume that all
players are risk averse with the same
are so they are they have exactly the
same risk attitudes subsequently we were
interested in finding if heterogeneity
of risk preferences leads to lower
system costs which it sometimes does and
sometimes doesn't so diversity doesn't
always help in the situation but most
importantly I really want to extend all
of these three thurs to dynamic models
or adaptive models first of all for
routing if we can adapt on the fly oh
we're way beyond so yeah so yeah let me
let me conclude here that basically the
goal is to develop an algorithm toolkit
for for risk mitigation in networks and
we have a lot of open problems I hope I
have convinced you that we may need
fundamentally different approaches in
both algorithms game theory and
mechanism design and ultimately I hope
that this theory will have impact in
various application domains such as
transportation smart grid and so on
thank you very much
you go back to the slide which I think
you skipped on you
will you be willing to say where did you
of course yeah yeah yeah of course so so
in the algorithmic part of the talk the
first part of the talk I only spoke
about static models so here is the graph
here is the information that we have
about random variable parameters and so
on what is the shortest path and i would
love to develop more dynamic or
real-time decision making framework in
there are different types currently in
the algorithmic community there are
different types of dynamic one is that
of the framework of online algorithms or
online learning another one is that of
adaptive dynamic models in the markov
decision process style so the first one
is for shortest paths again if I need to
take my route to work every day I
observe what happens on the previous
day's candid somehow inform me on my
route choice today and because of risk
averse attitudes how how does it change
existing online algorithms in a there
are bad there there isn't one player
you're right there a lot oh so I keep
switching back and forth between the
single player and multiple players this
I'm only thinking about single player so
far but you can also think about a game
theory the same the next day then yeah
here i'm not i'm not thinking about the
game here so i'm thinking simply about
the computation of the optimal path
adaptively if we think like a markov
decision process so here my shortest
path is a strategy how to go from here
to the airport i want to arrive there on
time and i can adapt my routing choice
at every intersection at every node how
do i do that if i have a risk-averse
utility function so this comes down to
risk averse it's related to risk averse
mark of decision processes about which
very little is known convicts
measures so I didn't mention that the
earlier results i mentioned that were
related to concave minimization were
possible because the problem was concave
and if the objective was instead convex
which we think of as an easier problem
convex minimization is actually harder
on combinatorial problems because the
relaxation of the convex problem may
fall on a on the vector that's that's
not a valid path it may be a convex
combination of paths and so we don't
really know how to solve convex
minimization problems for combinatorial
feasible sets so this is what i mean by
these bullets and again going to game
theory in mechanism design you can
extend all of these and beyond so this
is a very question it seems like if
there's a benevolent central entity it
should be able to incentivize people so
the price of risk aversion is avoided by
paying people if they get if they get
really they lose because of the risk and
taking money from people if so that's
that's uh that's an excellent it's an
excellent question and that's what i
mentioned at the very beginning there is
a very elegant theorem theory of optimal
tools which says that if we compute
tools they come at all the toll comes
down to being the derivative of the
latency function on every edge so if we
charge those tools so that users face
this latency function plus at all then
selfish players who play according to
this updated latency functions will
actually reach the socially optimal
traffic assignment and this is the
mechanism design in this case is this
set of tools but if instead travel times
are uncertain and we have those
risk-averse routing choices we don't
really know what happens to do this
theory doesn't hold anymore and so is
there an equivalent theory that has
again optimal tools that are edge based
or do we need at all which is depend
on the path choice maybe we won't be
able to decompose things into edges
because of the nonlinearities so we
don't really know so this is something
that that I'm currently working on
prevalence of braised paradox in
risk-averse travelers is it I mean okay
so you know it's a generalization so
every case that it's going to have a lot
of poise and x1 here but do you think
it's going to make great paradox it
could be worse but it's going to be more
prevalent because of this it's also a
really nice question on brace paradox
and would we observe it again and would
it be worse or better and so in this
work here where we considered
heterogeneous risk attitudes where
players minimize again min plus R times
variance but different hours for
different players we noticed connection
with brace paradox of it was not a
one-to-one connection so in instances
where there was braced paradox we
observe the diversity would would hurt
and the other way around but it wasn't
again it wasn't a one-to-one
correspondence break is getting shorter